some of the most common ways of turning
an object into a Talisman would be to
write on it the names of God in Arabic
primary of these is of course the name
Allah but one also find other names like
the merciful or Al the one Etc if not
God himself then one might write the
names of one or more of his angels such
as jabel or mik one can also write the
names of His prophets perhaps Muhammad
Moses or Solomon for many Shiites one
might also write the names of one of the
imams or spiritual successors to Prophet
Muhammad very common is also to write
the shahada or Muslim proclamation of
Faith there is no God but God or also
direct verses from the Quran many verses
like the aat or Throne verse were
thought to be especially powerful in
this sense in other words there was a
lot of writing on these talismans